Malcolm is in New York hey Malcolm
welcome to the Dave Ramsey show what are
you doing better than I deserve what's
up so I am uh I'm currently in college I
finished my first year at 4.0 GPA my
regulations
thank you I'm a pre-med I'm trying to
get into Medical School
excellent yeah so I have a dilemma that
so I I saved up money to uh to live in
New York while going to college so I
think rent of one thousand one hundred
dollars every month and I only had a
couple thousand saved up I'd believe it
at the start ahead around eight thousand
but now I'm nearing the end of the
amount of the money and my parents know
my parent my mom wants me to move back
in with her in Pennsylvania now there's
there's only there's only one college
near her within like a within like a for
our radius basically yeah yes so there's
only one college that gives a good
pre-med degree for me to go to medical
school that's right next to her and but
they will be they're gonna charge me
after federal aid they're gonna charge
me around ten thousand dollars a year
and I was wondering if it was worth it
to uh to take out a student loan to do
that or should I not and work and save
up the money and then go okay how are
you paying for the school you're in I'm
federal aid is actually paying for it
through my because my mom has a income
that that they so you know they cover
100 percent of the school year in 100%
in the college that's near her does not
cover 100% yes okay where does she live
in Pennsylvania
she lives in central PA right by
Gettysburg okay
okay so let's see one option is New York
which is twelve thousand dollars in rent
and free tuition the
other option is free rent and ten
thousand dollars out of pocket right yes
okay so it sounds like a break-even to
me I wonder is there wonder if there's a
third option
ah so I was I mean I could go to PA they
have a lot of factory jobs over there
and I was thinking I would just get a
factory job and save up the money but I
was wondering is it worth it to do that
than to just go straight into college
finish up as fast I can get into medical
school do medical school because I'm
gonna get I'm gonna get dead anyway
because medical school there's no one
going to pay for me for that so there I
mean they'll be able to cover someone
because doing good I should be able to
get a scholarship but uh but yeah it's
like I'm not sure if I should really ask
you this debt from starting from my four
year I was wondering if I should just
seem up that money for the four-year and
then you know start getting into debt
yeah it medically understand what you're
saying I'm just saying I think there
might be another option other than the
two you presented me there's an infinite
number of schools that do pre-med and
there's all kinds of different costs on
them and if your mom is set up to where
you qualify for Pell grants and you're
making a 4.0 I wonder if you can't get
scholarships and some other things and
go someplace where you live and go to
school free yeah that's what I would I
would love to do that but uh but you
just have found that in kind there kind
of really it's really hard for a
transfer student to actually get a good
scholarship to another caller like a
college like a scholarship in which they
give you money to live there too and
especially in New York it's pretty much
I mean the only ones they do that in
Manhattan and I really don't want to
live in Manhattan like I really don't
want to live there I don't want you to
either I'm just too expensive for you in
this situation but I think you've gotten
some bad information
there's untold billions of dollars of
scholarships to go and claimed every
year
and they can be used for anything some
of them are academic based some of them
are need-based the fun thing is is you
actually qualify for both of those as
well as all of the other scholarships
and so I think I'm going to put you on a
different track completely number one
let's just stop for a second I want you
to look at a third option or a fourth
option or eighth option because if the
two options that are in front of you
suck it means you don't have enough
options and that's what you've given me
or two bad options and so a third option
that comes to mind immediately is not
quit and go work a factory job to save
up
you only need $10,000 do you have a car
uh yes I have a car deliver pizzas every
night and you'll make $1,500 a night a
week and hour a month rather and you can
pay for ten thousand dollars with the
college fifteen hundred times twelve
months of work is $18,000 and you can
cashflow college while you're in it
while you work walk dogs cut grass I
don't care what you do but work at
something that's profitable and makes
you money not minimum wage but not a
factory job and then go to school during
the day and you know and pay cash that's
a possible third option I really think
you're gonna qualify for a whole bunch
of these other things that are out there
and so what I'm going to do is and
including medical school see what you
did is you just laid down you said okay
the two ways I know how to do it are
both $10,000 $12,000 short and so I'm
gonna have to go into debt worse than
that I'm gonna have to go into a lot of
debt to go to medical school and so what
you did was you just took a normal path
and that gets people deeply in debt and
deeply disillusioned and I don't
recommend that path instead I would tell
you there's actually ways to go to
medical school debt free there's a thing
called the MD ph.d program there are
fellowships there are scholarships there
are all kinds of things especially where
your mom has a lower income that
qualifies you for all kinds of
need-based things that should
up a ton of doors for you and you got a
4.0 your first year that should open up
a ton of doors for you so I think you've
got to narrow of vision I want you to
broaden your vision on where you might
go to school and where they might pay
for it and where more you can get some
scholarships and the type of work you
can do while you're doing your undergrad
and start investigating now how you're
gonna do medical school debt-free oh
there's a lot of work for you to do
young man hold on we're gonna send you a
copy of a book called debt-free degree
which is what you and I are discussing
by number one best-selling author
Anthony O'Neill it's a number one
bestseller and it will walk you
step-by-step through exactly what I'm
talking about and go to Anthony's
website and look at the scholarship
search tool and go to Anthony's website
and read about anything that he's got on
there to help you get through school
debt-free and this book will help you as
well so you hold on I'll send that to
you and broaden your options so good
question